hi guys markiplier here hope you're
having a great day wherever you are in
the world I just wanted to say a few
things first and foremost of course is
to thank you guys again for the amazing
support that you've been giving me I
can't even put it into words how much
you mean to me and how much this channel
means to me and you may have noticed
that recently I've been putting a ton of
more work into both the thumbnails and
and the videos that I've been doing I've
been putting more effort into the
editing and making sure that it's an
entertaining video and not just
something that's entertaining for you
but something that I would want to watch
myself which is very important to me in
and one of the driving factors behind me
having YouTube channel is to you know
make content that I would want to see
that I'm proud of not just shilling it
out trying to get views every day so I
am grateful for people recognizing this
and the amazing fan art that's been
coming out if you haven't been following
tumblr or devianart you've been seeing
these really really creative creations
and I'm so happy to see people getting
involved in you know recently I've been
looking back on my older videos you know
way back when like a year ago and you
may have noticed that I posted my old
chubby bunny video where I stuffed
marshmallows in my mouth and tried to
say chubby bunny and I was made in
celebration of getting 500 subscribers
and you know oh I get 500 subscribers in
a few hours and and you know I I was you
know I say that like I'm proud of it but
I have to say that back then I was so
unbelievably appreciative of everything
in and one thing that struck kind of
home for me was the fact that people
have been saying that you know I don't
respond to my fans or I don't care and
that couldn't be any farther from the
truth and in fact now I try harder than
ever to make sure that I I maintained an
open dialogue with my fans and make sure
that I respond to emails who make sure
that I respond to Twitter posts and
answer questions and stuff like that
it's just it's hard
you know you lose something down the
road when you're trying to grow your
channel bigger you lose a lot of it in
and back then I had this amazing
personal connection with each of my
subscribers you know back when it could
have been you know 500 subscribers it's
much easier to talk to everyone and make
sure that everyone wants who wants to
talk not everyone wants to talk to me
who watches my videos but those that did
I was able to respond to everyone and
now it's a lot harder you know it's
actually impossible to do and it it
really does get to me that that's not
there anymore it's a nostalgic factor
that's just kind of you know gone out of
my grasp and I can't have that anymore
and so I really wish I could but I can't
so the best I can do is just try to
convince you on a daily basis that I do
really truly appreciate every single one
of my subscribers and I wish I could
show it personally I really do but I
just can't anymore
and that's just something that I have to
accept but there is something that I
want you guys to see and it's very very
important if you click on annotations
that will be popping up here here here
here or right on my face again that's
where people used to like to click just
click anywhere here or it's in the
description you can find it it's a video
that my fans made for the twenty
thousand subscriber milestone video and
it's it's an extremely touching video
because it shows the direct appreciation
that fans had for me and and I was so
moved by that if you've been wondering
like some of you have been seeing this
video work someone made that where I'm
crying um I made a veal AAG as I was
watching the video I decided to you know
it's gonna record something in in the
end and I just kind of opened up my
webcam and I just started recording
myself watching this and I literally
broke down into tears especially when
Bob said he was of an exceptionally
close friend of mine he's Bob from drunk
minecraft um we've been friends for
years I consider him one of my very best
friends and he just moved away recently
to North Carolina and we had our last
lunch together earlier this weekend you
know I'm I'm sad that he's gone away
because you know there's not many people
that I would consider my close friends
and the fact that we won't be able to
get lunch together really meant
something to me and I went back and I
saw this video and I saw his words which
are right at the end of the video so you
got to go through the whole thing to see
him and they just kind of they moved me
to tears again because it's just so
sincere and I'm so happy that you know
other people recognize it too and even
my best friend
the words that he says coincide with
what everyone else was saying and and he
you know it it's something that I don't
want to ever lose yeah
I didn't start this channel for you know
extreme Fame I didn't do it for that I
did it because you know I wanted I
wanted to make people laugh and I'd like
to think that I'm still doing it today
you know I want to entertain people I
want to scare people sometimes you know
I've done creepypasta videos like I have
in the past for you know just random
occasions because I wanted to spook
things out I did you know quite a few
things like that you can find them if
you dig around in my old videos it's
hard to find with thousands of videos
but um just click watch that video it's
really important to me and I'm I'm still
grateful to this day that people took
the time to make that video and put the
effort into sending a message to me that
they appreciate what I've done and and
that's you know that makes all my effort
worth it you know just knowing that
people appreciate what I do
you know and I want people know that
it's equal you know I appreciate you
guys watching it and the impact that my
videos have on you just the same so
sincerely thank you and please watch
that video you know you can watch the
response I made it as a response to my
video but it's not vice-versa so you
just look up the same name it says re :
same name so you can probably find it
and you'll see me bawling like a baby
but anyway so thank you guys again for
that but on to other news there is other
stuff that I wanted to talk about I
didn't mean to go on for this long about
this I apologize it's just something
that's really close to my heart and
something that I'm very very very
grateful for so the other thing very
important I'm very excited about this is
that I have a new t-shirt how cool is
that
yeah it's this is the brand new design
it was made for me by a rodeo arcade
which is uh if you've ever ordered
t-shirts of youtubers and gamer stuff
really high quality t-shirts come from
rody Arcade they made this design for me
they worked around the clock to make
sure that the design that I wanted was
um was met and it's actually really it's
one of the nicest t-shirts that I've
ever had it's a little more expensive
than my Spreadshirt ones but it comes
through in the quality because it's not
it's not like just a Hanes t-shirt that
they grabbed off of a multi packing and
ironed on the thing the the design
actually feels like the design is part
of the shirt and it doesn't flake it's
not faded around the edges it's like
sincerely one of the highest quality
graphics I've seen and it's a limited
edition thing it's not going to be
around forever so get it while you can
but at the same time it's just like I
like it because it's also long it goes
down a bit and which I really appreciate
and it's just like a really really cool
teacher and I haven't gotten a new
t-shirt in a while so if you want to
find that that's in the description too
you can find that buy some or not you
know it doesn't matter I don't really do
this to push t-shirts but if you guys
want a cool t-shirt this one is
high-quality it really is comfortable it
doesn't feel like just cotton or
anything if you
like I don't know it's really nice it
doesn't have a tag so it doesn't say
what it is so I'm just assuming that it
that it's really cool and I really like
this design with the Worf stash in them
combining the two symbols that have been
pretty prevalent in my channel so anyway
that's the other thing that I just
wanted to I'm pretty I really like it's
t-shirt it's really cool I'm not trying
to push it for salesmanship I just I
really like to teacher him you know I
still get tickled by this sort of stuff
because you know a year ago I'd ever
imagine I didn't have a teacher job in a
year ago I didn't have people that a
company that was like oh we gotta get
you a t-shirt we got to make you this
we're gonna work around the clock
because I went through like a ton of
designs was like I don't like it I don't
like it I don't I love that and I love
this design and you know I never
imagined I'd be in this pushing you know
I was at comic-con I met Jesse Cox and
Dodger and I was livid you know I was
like amazed you know they probably
thought I was a weirdo because I just I
ran up to him and I was so excited to
see him and Jesse Cox gave me a hug and
it felt warm and I was just the greatest
feeling in the world and um you know I
was so tickled that I got to meet these
great guys and you know because I've
been so lucky as a youtuber and have
been so lucky to just be a part of this
and I've been lucky to have such great
fans that have pushed me from nothing
like back in the chubby bunny video
500 subscribers compared to everyone
else I mean to me that 500 is incredibly
important but to everyone else on
YouTube that was nothing and I'm here I
get to meet these people and I'm so
happy that I get to do when I'm so
grateful that you guys have been
supporting me this whole time and you
know I I'm getting back on the same
track that I was going on before but
it's can't convey the message enough
that this is really really really
important to me and I apologize tickle
my throat I'm about to cough I'm sorry I
still have had that cough just hanging
around for quite some time but seriously
you know I used to remember
way back when I used to remember my
videos would get you know a couple
hundred views per video and when they
start bumping up against the thousand
view barrier I was like oh my god I
really oh I'm making it this is
incredible so many people love my videos
and you know now my video is every
single one gets between a hundred
thousand and two hundred thousand now I
have to slap myself in the face every
once in a while just cuz you know it
doesn't seem real and you know it's
thing and you know it's exciting but
then I you know I go back and I watch
those old videos in like I get sad
because you know I don't have that you
know what I was talking about before I
don't have the personal connection you
know that's I guess that's the price you
have to pay and you know I didn't I
don't I don't mean to be downer about it
I really do love the fact that I can
reach so many people and I know I know
that the more people that we have the
more good we can do I mean we've been
raising so much money for charity and
I'm so grateful for every every bit of
that but at the same time I just want
you guys to know that you know I've
never really lost touched with the fact
that I came from nothing and I had this
really close personal relationship with
my fans
I hope I hope you guys still realize
that that I care because I do so anyway
I've been rambling long I've been
rambling long enough I'm gonna close up
shop so anyway thank you guys so much
for everything that you've done
remember the links to the videos are in
the description or you could have go
back click the annotation on my face
there might be an annotation for this
church shop I have no idea but if you
know yeah annotations turned off just
check the description it's there so
sincerely from the bottom of my heart I
know this v-log went way longer than I
ever anticipated but sincerely thank you
guys so much for watching
always I'm never not appreciative of my
fans so thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye